objectif pour saint cyr l'école
accueillir fin 2020 le tram très express
qui reliera la ville à saint germain en
laye en 30 minutes
les travaux préparatoires ont eu lieu en
2017 le tram très entrera en
correspondance avec le rer c est avec
les lignes n ai eu à la gare de saint
césaire pour transporter 4 millions de
voyageurs par an
la tangentielle ouest permettra dans les
années à venir à désenclaver la ville et
à limiter les embouteillages depuis le
début des travaux pour le tram 13 la
ville peinent à se désengorger
embouteillages déviation et routes
barrées se sont installés dans les rues
de saint cyr autre enjeu revaloriser le
centre ville et le patrimoine de saint
cyr pour que la commune ne devienne pas
qu'une ville dortoir de plus la ville
manque de places de stationnement et de
trottoirs ce qui empêche les riverains
de rejoindre le centre facilement
incivilités tensions entre bandes
rivales
la sécurité est un des enjeux de la
campagne pas de caméra de sécurité
encore dans les quartiers sensibles
de plus certains candidats dénoncent un
manque d'agents de voirie et de police
de proximité
une ville qui a grandement évolué au fil
des années notamment avec la
construction du quartier charles renard
depuis maintenant 12 ans les travaux
sont en cours mais 500 logements sur les
25 hectares de terrains destinés à
accueillir de nouveaux centres ayant un
enjeu majeur pour la ville qui doit
maintenant mettre en place des
structures pour accueillir les habitants
car la commune va voir sa population
passer de 15 à 20 mille habitants